[Music]
to define more precisely however the
relationship of these two aspects in the
organic shape this shape is in one
aspect turned against its inorganic
nature well in the other it is for
itself and reflected on to itself the
actual organism is the middle term which
unites the being for self of life with
the outer in general or with being in
itself the extreme of being for self is
however the inner is an infinite one
which takes back into itself out of
their subsistence and connection without
ur nature the moments of shape itself it
is that which without a content of its
own gives itself a content in its shape
and appears in shape as its process in
this extreme where it is a simple
negativity or a pure singular the
organism possesses its absolute freedom
in virtue of which it is indifferent
towards and secured against being for
other and the determinate Ness of the
moments of shape this freedom is at the
same time freedom of the moments
themselves it is their possibility of
appearing as an outer existence and of
being apprehended as such and just as in
this freedom they are free and
indifferent towards this outer existence
so - are they in relation to one another
for the simplicity of this freedom is
being or is their simple substance this
notion or pure freedom is one in the
same life no matter how many and varied
its shapes or its being for other it is
a matter of indifference to this stream
of life what kind of Mills it strives
now in the first place it is to be noted
that this notion is not to be understood
here as it was formerly when we were
considering the properly inner in its
form of process or the development of
its moments but in its form of a simple
inner which constitutes the purely
universal aspect in contrast to the
actual living being or as the element in
which the existent members of the
organic shape have their subsistence for
it is this shape that we are considering
here and in it the essence of life is
present as the simplicity of subsistence
in the next place the the being for
other or the determinate nests of the
actual structured shape is taken up into
this simple universality which is its
essence a determinate 'no switch is
equally simple universal and non
sensuous and can only be that which is
expressed in number this determinant is
the middle term of the shape which links
indeterminate life with the actual life
simple like the former and determinate
like the latter that which in the former
the inner would be expressed numerically
the outer would have to express in
accordance with its mode as a multi form
actuality that is as its manner of life
color and so on
in general as the entire host of
differences which are developed in the
world of appearance
paragraph 285 introduces for us some
very important clarifications about
where Hegel is going with this and you
notice that he's going to talk about
life in in general or life you might say
in a metaphysical or ontological sense
no longer that merely of the living
organism but you know capital a life or
in all-caps life something that he
talked about earlier on in the beginning
of the self consciousness section and
now which is coming back to the fore in
this section not that it hasn't in
previous paragraphs where he was
discussing you know teleology and living
things being intended themselves but
this is a very important turning point
here I think and remember when we're
talking about the Hegelian system or
Hegelian phenomenology this is one of
those places where the full meaning of
our table or sublation comes to life you
know we don't just move simply from one
stage to the next been there done that
and then we leave it behind and say you
know we don't need that anymore we're
bringing it into a more and more complex
way of looking at things a fuller grasp
of reality yeah so that's going to
assume a major role here you notice also
on this schema that we've got this
middle term because in this this
paragraph Hegel is once again using his
in essence metaphorical language about
referring back to the syllogism that is
you know some sort of connected process
of inference or reasoning hangul really
likes to think in terms of this
traditional Aristotelian way of doing
things where the middle term is is the
key thing for you to find because that's
will allows you to bring together to the
extreme terms although the middle term
is always you know functioning in
different ways for Hegel again if you
want to know more about that the place
to go is actually
science of logic where he discusses that
so all that said by way of preface let's
take a look at at this paragraph he says
to define more precisely the
relationship of these two aspects in the
organic shape what are the two aspects
in the organic shape the the outer and
the fact that the outer itself has an
inner and an outer as we talked about so
he says the shape is in one aspect
turned against its inorganic nature
right the shape the Gestalt of the the
form of the living thing is turn against
its inorganic nature that which it is
going to arise from its environment
right it certainly its predecessors the
bits of stuff that it's made of the
organic beings are made of organic
compounds which are themselves you know
you can break them down into inorganic
things as well right so he says the
shape is turned against its inorganic
nature well in the other it is for
itself in reflected into itself
now before itself that we're talking
about over here is going to be referring
to being for itself in a general way so
he says the actual organism the thing
that we've been looking at this entire
time to think we've been attempting to
try to provide laws governing laws
providing the intelligibility for our
understandings that is a middle or
mediating term between these two
extremes so what are the extremes this
is where we get very metaphysical and
some of the questions that people have
been asking about you know what is the
for itself but what is the in itself you
know oftentimes trying to trying to you
know aim for something with as simple as
what Sartre said about it and being a
nothingness and I've always responded
look for itself and in itself don't
always mean exactly the same thing in
every context but this is one where we
see something like the core of the the
for itself in terms
consciousness of these or in terms of
responsiveness to itself yeah in itself
Hegel says the actual organism is the
middle term which has this this function
of uniting the beating for self of life
notice he doesn't say the being for
herself of consciousness this is a
broader the beating for self of life
we've talked about this quite a lot
there's a sort of infinite
reflectiveness within the the living
being that allows it to adapt itself to
what is over here in itself right and
then he says it is the middle term which
unites it with the outer in general or
with being in itself right being that
simply is what it is being that in a
certain way has its meaning if it has
meaning at all only for something that
is for itself this is the mediating term
the actual living organism so we have
things that you might say are in a
certain respect metaphysically prior or
metaphysically more Universal or more
widespread these two extremes and then
we have individual organism but it's not
really individual organism as if there
was only one organism in the world that
would be a very strange thing wouldn't
it it's rather individual organisms this
you know a whole variety of living
things and we're going to get to that
and why that matters in just a moment so
he goes on he says the extreme of being
for self he tells us a bit more about
this right is no surprise the inner has
infinite one infinite unity which takes
back into itself out of their
subsistence in connection with outer
nature the moments of shape itself it is
that which without a content of its own
gives a content
that shape and appears in in shape as
its process so we don't actually have
there isn't let's just say it that way
there isn't anything that we can point
to and say aha there's life itself
Hinkle was not postulating life itself
as something like a platonic form which
would exist in a more real way than all
the things that participate in it that's
not the the way in which this is working
it's more like the Aristotelian
Universal which exists only in its
instantiation in its particulars or in
our cognizant you might say image or we
if you want to use the term
participation there you could certainly
do that participation in it so life
itself takes in when we consider what
life is life takes in all of these these
shapes that are living things and
provides them with their capacity for
responsiveness for a reflexive Nisour
all the things that separate it out from
mere or inorganic nature which is
essentially static I mean it does cool
stuff when we carry out say chemistry
experiments or physical experiments but
it doesn't of its own accord do all of
those things I mean we could talk about
astronomy and how stars come into being
that's all very great stuff but none of
it is even remotely like what happens in
a single-celled organism and that's part
of what Hegel is driving it of course
not I was having the conception of
single-cell organisms at this point so
you don't have any sense in this extreme
where it is a simple negativity or a
pure singular the organism possesses its
absolute freedom freedom is absolute at
this extreme it is what we might call a
condition
or better yet determinate freedom
freedom exercise in certain ways and
appearing sometimes as something
something that's merely determined
that's happy to be what it is precisely
because something free occurred the more
that goes towards this side I think it
might be helpful as you're thinking
through this rather than thinking three
punctual spots on here to think in terms
of a continuum or a back-and-forth of
interaction this mediating term is the
Nexus where the outer in general though
the world connects up with life in
general as something in the world
through living organisms so he goes on
he says the the organism possesses its
absolute freedom in virtue of which it
is in different tours and secured
against those very important in
different you can afford to stand back
and say well I understand that the the
environment is grassy and cold yeah if
you would seem to dictate to me that I
should respond in such in such a way but
I'm not going to I'm gonna do something
different instead right now of course
it's not conscious process that the
animal or even the plant goes through
where the fungus goes through it in
doing that but there's a kind of
slippage there the outside environment
does not fully determine it has a kind
of indifference to it a difference
allows it to be as Hegel says secured
against it the organism is not merely a
reflection of its environment what we
might call you know formal mechanistic
causality the way that some people like
to think of nature working which is
actually based on the macula you know
magnetizable model that that involves an
awful lot of imaginary leaves isn't the
way that living things really work
according to Hegel Hegel is working with
a somewhat different conception here
though the problem with that conception
by the way this is a side note is always
hot
keep it from turning into a
loosey-goosey anything goes you know
life just finds a way a kind of mess
that would be the case if all we have is
this how do we stick to the the
actuality of living organisms but that's
a that's a separate question but one
that's worth worth keeping a bike so he
goes on he says it's secured against
beating for other right and the
determinant nests of the moments of
shape now why is he talking about being
for other well the organism itself as
we've seen is insofar as it is external
it is being for other one is the other
in this case Hegel is just pulled us in
the previous paragraphs it is the outer
in general or inorganic nature I think
what we also have to keep in mind if we
want to be a bit more realistic at this
point is that we're not just saying the
inorganic nature but also other life
right because the environment does
include other things
kinga wants to keep it a bit more simple
in its considerations we're going to
talk about another life but we've
already seen how this figures in in
terms of the self consciousness section
right life and how it relates to other
way other than life how it relates to
another consciousness so we have being
per self which is what is involved in
the organism right being for other which
is what allows us this juncture point
and being in itself here all of these
are connected with each other
all of them are distinguishable and
thought but all of them are part of the
one same world in which all of these
things are are taking place so he says
I'm going back to this freedom this
freedom is at the same time freedom of
the moments themselves it is their
possibility of appearing as an outer
existence and of being apprehended as
such very important point
freedom is exercised this way but you
might say it's also Xers
this way through the organism right the
organism is to a certain degree able to
determine itself it can't of course said
well I think I need five extra like so
let's have you know is that that sort of
thing it is working within certain
constraints but life affords it a kind
of freedom from determinism you know
sort of a temporary freedom from
determinism because it is intermeshing
with a determined and deterministic
outside environment then it has to
somehow fit into you
as a sidenote to by the way if you want
to see somebody who really took these
sorts of thoughts quite seriously in a
somewhat different context another
dialectical philosophers sometimes
called the french angle or the catholic
Hegel you would want to take a look at
Maurice bloom Dells Loxy on 1893 because
he is dealing with the same sort of
problematic there he had a number of
different levels the the freedom and
determinism understood in a different
sense not in the sense that we do in
philosophy of action where freedom and
determinism are somehow polar opposites
or somehow perhaps compatible but in a
much more nuanced manner
all right so back to this he says
freedom is at the same time freedom of
the moments themselves just as in this
freedom they are free and indifferent
towards this outer existence so - they
are in relation to one another so the
living organism is in a certain respect
as we've seen you know by thinking about
this in terms of you know those three
functions of reproduction sensibility
and irritability and the possibility
that there could be plenty of other ones
as well there's a certain degree of
freedom of those in relation to each
other as well but that's part of what it
means to be a living being again to
participate in or to embody better than
participate in life so he goes on and he
says the simplicity of this freedom is
being or is there simple
this notion or pure freedom is one and
the same life no matter how many in
varied its shapes or its being for other
none there's there's a little bit of a
typo here in the Miller text where it
says it is a matter of indifference in
here we go to this stream of life what
kind of Mills it
it's drives it shouldn't hit drives
rather than its drives this is just a
proverb there it doesn't matter what
kind of water wheels it is good as
driving you know producing power for for
grinding flour that's with MELAS it
doesn't really matter in this respect
what life capital L is embodying itself
in in terms of specific organisms as a
matter of fact its embodying itself at
any given point in time in an entire
host of organisms we can think of this
not only in terms of you know species
over time you know there may have been I
mean we assume that there was one
original living thing at one point in
time and then once you've got that we
have all these other things that arise
from them right even though it's just a
vision of one species now we have
multiple individuals within that species
and those multiple individuals are
different from each other act
differently are worked upon by their
environment different they respond to it
differently now we added back in the
river floor information of species and
then let's just give it static let's not
even think in terms of evolution yeah
right we have a hundred species right
let's keep kind of small even though
that is just a minuscule amount of them
number of species that have developed
even the number of species that have
gone extinct over time right hundred
species and each one of them has a
hundred different individuals right
they're keeping it very very small
that's what life is doing it's taking
all these different forms and in a
certain respect like Hegel says it's
indifferent which particular form
kake's there's a for any form it takes
you can always take another form that's
one of the dimensions of its freedom
which means that for any given organism
it is an embodiment of that freedom and
also in a certain respect something like
the leftover of that freedom now you
know adding to that picture imagine the
entire panorama of evolution if you can
if you could put that into your head
because we didn't really only imagine
that and we can only imagine it in very
cursory ways where we're doing you know
essentially mental metaphors to even try
to conceptualize what the you know how
evolution must have worked over time
pretty pretty mind-blowing stuff going
we beyond to what people the theory of
evolution you know it's not the theory
of evolution that we should be
particularly worried about for my
yelling in perspective it's the
conception of evolution thinking it
through now we don't necessarily need to
do that like angle says this is kind of
a matter of indifference we don't need
to think about every little species of
ant even though I'm really into ants or
bees or things like that but we do need
to coming back to the text think about
is the fact that like he says this this
notion of pure freedom is one of the
same life no matter how many and varied
its shapes for its being for other it is
a matter of indifference right he says
in the first place is to be noted that
this notion is not to be understood here
as it was formerly how in terms of
process or the development of moments
but in terms of a simple inner which is
then being externalized through the
freedom that is you might say not just
being exercised in relation to being in
itself what it is is actually being
produced we don't think this is another
aside but lots of the sides in this this
commentary here but you'll forgive me
for that we often think of freedom as
something
like a property that you have like you
have a certain amount of freedom and
then you dispose of it like you you
spend your monthly income or you know
you you eat you know the amount of food
that's in your of your pantry right
freedom isn't really long except freedom
exists in part through its exercise
which creates that very freedom and you
know what does it created out of and you
know in some respects you can say well
nothing I mean this is where somebody
like Heidegger in what is metaphysics is
getting at something very fundamental
very the society note let's come back to
this but I think it's important to keep
in mind so we don't have the wrong
conception of freedom or rather an
inadequate consumption of freedom so he
says here we go it's this shape that we
are considering here right the shape of
the thing and in it the essence of life
is present as the simplicity of
subsistence in the next place the being
for other or the determinate nests of
the actual structured shape is taken up
into the simple universality which is
its essence a determinant Ness which is
equally simple Universal and non
sensuousness and can only be that which
is expressed in number now doesn't that
strike you as a strange thing for Hegel
to say it can only be expressed in
number saw in German notice he doesn't
say magnitude
he doesn't say quantity he says number
at this point we could in fact read all
the remarks that he's saying in the past
which were fairly majority I'm afraid
I'm out of mathematics about quantity
about magnitude and it's going to turn
out in the next paragraph number is not
going to be particularly helpful for us
but this is one of the ways in which
people were at the time trying to make
sense out of this thinking in terms of
could we perhaps you know a sign
some sort of numbers to this and he's
going to hold that out as a possibility
in this paragraph so he says there we go
expressed a number this determinate is
the middle term of the shape which links
indeterminate life with the actual life
simple life the former determinate like
the latter that which in the former of
the inner would be expressed numerically
right the inner and the inner here
numerically would be expressed
differently in in the outer there we go
the ammeter would have to express in
accordance with its mode as multiform
actuality that is as its manner of life
color at the center in general has the
entire host of differences which are
developed in the world of appearance so
as we move from this the inner to the
outer and the outer is sort of the
engagement with the outside world the
outer in general what we have is some
sort of you know number to be determined
yet here on this side and it's
expressing itself in the outer qualities
the outer characteristics having you
know here on the face as opposed to
feathers having a certain kind of shape
bipedal locomotion neveress eating a
little bit of play-doh handsome there
and eating everything eating but uh this
is where the the locus is going to take
place interestingly what we see that is
determinism happens most
deterministically for Hindle in terms of
quality over here not in terms of what
we're calling so far number or quantity
over here
if the two aspects of the organic whole
the one being the inner while the other
is the outer in such a way that each
again has in its own self an inner and
an outer are compared with reference to
the inner which each aspect has then the
inner of the first aspect was the notion
it has the unrest of abstraction the
second however has for its inner a
quiescent universality which also
involves a quiescent determinate Ness if
therefore the first inner because the
notion develops its moments in it made a
deceptive promise of laws on account of
the show of necessity in the
relationship
the second directly disclaims doing so
since number shows itself to be the
determination of one aspect of its laws
for number is just that completely
quiescent lifeless and indifferent
determinate Ness in which all movement
and relation is extinguished and which
has broken the bridge to the living
element of instincts manner of life and
other aspects of sensuous existence
after the long paragraph that preceded
it which we saw is so rich in
reflections paragraph 286 seems somewhat
insipid and doesn't really say an awful
lot to us that that we don't already
have mind but let's take a look at it
nonetheless he says if the two aspects
of the organic poll the worrying as
someone's we've been talking about
though I'm being interviewed misery is
the outer in such a way that each has an
inner and outer to itself if we compare
them to Asia now he's not interested in
in showing us the whole general
structure of relations of them but if we
compare them to each other on this
particular point he says with respect or
with reference to the inner which each
aspect yes then the inner of the first
aspect was the notion as the unrest of
abstraction what's important there is
and we're talking about the the notion
but not the notion is completely
developed at this point but having that
that that that quality that the notion
has of being dynamic right of being
wooden religion in German non non static
non restful by contrast the inner of the
outer right so they call it the external
inner frame that he said the second is
for its inner a quiescent that is
restful universality which also involves
acquiescence determinate Ness of resting
a static determinant this a man is
number so we've got a contrast here
right he goes on he says if therefore
the first inner because the notion
develops its moments in it may a
deceptive promise of laws we've seen
that in the previous paragraph we don't
get laws providing us with this inner
you know expressing itself in the hour
in a way that provides us with an
intelligibility that runs throughout the
entire thing
and gives us the necessity of it well at
the same time doing justice to teleology
doing justice to freedom we we tried
that and that has failed throughout this
entire section and what we're interested
in now it isn't so much that we're
interested in what is going on over here
right why because we are looking at the
outer seeing whether maybe we couldn't
derive a law in that way and he says
okay we wanted to make a comparison here
what's the comparison he says the second
doesn't try to make laws why not number
shows itself to be the determination of
one aspect of its laws number it doesn't
provide us with laws number is you might
say the building blocks for the laws it
can't give us the laws themselves so
that's a problem if our whole goal was
to try to find and provide laws we're
not getting what it is that were we're
after here are we so he says no why not
number is just that completely restful
quiescent lifeless and indifferent
determinate 'no sin which all the
movement and relation is extinguished
and which has broken the bridge to the
living element of here I'm trying to
locate these instincts maybe we place
those in the inner the outer of the
inner manner of life way of being in the
world that he just says and other
aspects of sensuous existence now this
is this is talking about where we've
managed to get to at this point because
there are still plenty of people who
think that number magnitude are going to
provide us with laws Hinkel just at this
point says that they're wrong and now
that we're considering this we see that
this isn't actually giving us what it is
that we're looking for in terms of law
and why is that important well because
observing reason has been this entire
time
attempting to not only provide or find
but to impose laws upon what it's
observing